avant qu'on vous dise de partir.
J'ai grandi à Atlanta, en Géorgie,
déménageant de maison en maison,
au sein d'une famille aimante et unie,
mais devant faire face à des difficultés
d'ordre financier.
Quand ma mère a été en proie à des troubles de l'humeur
et qu'elle a fait de moi son principal bouc émissaire,
abusée physiquement et psychologiquement,
j'ai fui pour ma sécurité.
J'en étais arrivée à la conclusion que j'étais plus en sécurité dans la rue
qu'à la maison.
J'avais 16 ans.
Durant cette période, j'ai été l'une des 3 300 jeunes sans-abris d'Atlanta,
me sentant comme eux abandonnée,
délaissée et invisible chaque nuit.
Il n'y avait et il n'y a toujours aucun lieu
permettant à un jeune sans-abri de quitter la rue
pour un lit.
J'ai réalisé que pour la plupart des gens,
sans-abris rime avec paresse, misère, drogue et dérangement.
Mais mon sac à dos plein de vêtements et de livres de classe,
et mes excellentes notes disaient le contraire.
Je m'asseyais sur mon banc préféré en ville
et regardais passer les heures,
jusqu'à ce que je puisse grappiller quelques heures de sommeil
sur des canapés, dans des voitures,
dans des bâtiments ou des hangars.
Comme des milliers d'autres, je me fondais dans les ombres de la ville,
tandis que le monde continuait à tourner
comme si rien de terrible ne s'était produit.
Être ainsi invisible m'a presque complètement brisée mentalement.
Pourtant, quand je n'avais rien, il me restait l'art,
qui n'exigeait de moi
aucune contrepartie matérielle en échange d'un refuge
Ce sont les quelques heures à chanter, à écrire des poèmes
ou économiser suffisamment
pour m'évader dans un autre monde au théâtre,
qui m'ont aidée à avancer et m'accrocher lorsque je touchais le fond.
J'allais à la messe les mercredis soir
et, assoiffée du réconfort que les arts m'apportaient,
j'arrivais quelques heures en avance,
me glissais à l'étage du dessous
et dans ce recoin du monde où seul importait
ma capacité à atteindre la bonne note dans la chanson
que je répétais la semaine.
Je chantais des heures durant.
Ça me rendait tellement forte de m'autoriser
à tout oublier et simplement chanter.
Cinq ans plus tard, j'ai fondé ChopArt,
un organisme multidisciplinaire pour les mineurs sans-abris.
ChopArt utilise les arts comme outil de guérison
en prenant nos connaissances sur la construction d'une communauté
et le recouvrement de la dignité,
et en l'appliquant au processus créatif.
ChopArt est basé à Atlanta, en Géorgie,
et offre d'autres programmes à Hyderabad, en Inde et à Accra, au Ghana
et depuis nos débuts, en 2010,
nous avons aidé plus de 40 000 adolescents à travers le monde.
Nos ados se réfugient
dans le caractère transformateur des arts
et ils sont dépendants du lieu sûr que ChopArt leur fournit pour y arriver.
Une population souvent invisible utilise les arts pour se découvrir,
mais ce voyage hors de l'invisibilité n'est pas facile.
Nous avons une paire de frères et sœurs nommés Jeremy et Kelly,
qui ont été dans notre programme pendant plus de trois ans.
Ils venaient aux classes de ChopArt tous les mercredis soir.
Mais il y a environ un an,
Jeremy et Kelly ont vu leur mère mourir devant eux.
Ils ont regardé les ambulanciers ne parvient pas à la ranimer.
Ils pleuraient pendant que leur père
signait la garde temporaire à leur mentor ChopArt, Erin,
sans les permettre prendre d'autres vêtements en quittant la maison.
Cette série d'événements m'a brisé le cœur,
mais la foi et la détermination de Jeremy et Kelly en ChopArt,
c'est ce qui me maintient ancrée dans ce travail.
Quand Kelly a touché le fond et a appelé Erin,
en savant qu'Erin fera tout ce qu'elle peut
pour que Kelly et Jeremy se sentent aimés et soignés,
c'est bien la preuve qu'en utilisant les arts comme point d'entrée,
nous pouvons guérir et développer notre population de jeunes sans-abris.
Et nous continuons à la développer.
Nous nous développons avec Devin,
qui est devenu sans-abri avec sa famille
quand sa mère devrait choisir entre ses factures médicales ou le loyer.
Il a découvert son amour de la peinture grâce à ChopArt.
Nous nous développons avec Liz,
qui était à la rue pour la majorité de ses années d'adolescence,
mais qui écoute à la musique pour se retrouver
quand ses traumatismes sont trop lourds pour ses jeunes épaules.
Nous nous développons pour Maria,
qui utilise la poésie pour se guérir
après que son grand-père est mort dans la camionnette
où elle habite avec le reste de sa famille.
Alors, pour les autres jeunes sans-abris,
laissez-moi vous dire
que vous avez la force en vous pour vous développer.
Vous avez une voix grâce à l'art
qui ne juge pas ce que vous avez rencontré.
Alors, n'arrêtez jamais de combattre pour vous découvrir
car même dans vos temps les plus sombres,
nous vous voyons.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)